je pense que aujourd'hui celui qui va
trop loin
s'il a choisi de la politique du pire
c'est le président erdogan est un homme
qui choisit la politique du pire
philippaerts s'égarer et ils ne voient
effectivement que le pire est son
attitude menaçante à l'égard de tous
ceux qui ne partagent pas son preneur
elle est devenue menaçante à l'égard de
notre pays
eh bai est là
des bateaux qui ont des attitudes qui ne
sont pas prévus dans le cadre de la
navigation ou dans les cordes du bien
vivre sur les mers au revoir des
projecteurs pour éblouir les pilotes
français ça ne se fait pas d'autant
grenet de pays de l'otan
si les choses a encore un sens ce genre
de gars à une inspiration marc vision
qui l'arrangent en tout cas et rooney
certainement de ce que fut la pire
ottoman et ils veulent reconstituer aux
seules fins de tenir son tacle ce grand
peuple turc pour qui j'ai table de
respect parce que la turquie est un
grand pays et qui ne mérite pas d'être
traité de cette manière là et il va se
servir de cette attitude pour remettre
du feu
partout où la paix revenait il veut
faire croire à l'opinion qu'il est
d'accord avec monsieur poutine jeu
poutine n'a pas cette attitude là c'est
poutine n'a pas tenu cette attitude dans
cette partie du monde
il n'a pas retenu cette attitude
aciéries et j'ai dit à mon ami
heureusement que ma charest la sadc pas
du tout le sentiment devant p je
m'inscris totalement en opposition avec
ce qui est dit opposition dans le débat
démocratique
mais inversement que la syrie est au
niveau
heureusement là c'est avec son armée de
conscription l'aide de la russie c'est
vrai mais en face avec tous les autres a
tenu bon
et je souhaite je dédie à la ministre
nous avons parlé et au généralissime
désormais que nous reprenons le plus
rapidement possible comme d'hab avec
bachar el-assad qui a vécu l'armée de
conscription a permis à ce pays de tenir
si dans à l'image de l'irak de la limite
de l'iva cette partie du monde que nous
aimons tant et qui est si chère à la
france seraient déjà qu'on aimerait
semblable en faire de feu
oui pour la politique à doha mais pour
dire aussi à monsieur le président la
république française emmanuel macron et
l'ensemble des dirigeants européens
nos frères qui suivent cette politique
de la peur que la paire n'a jamais rien
résolu et que la france est un pays de
résistance est un pays à l'image de ce
qu'est la série aujourd'hui